o unfortunately, you know, I didn't realize
on November 8th that this outrageous slate
of radical Republican members of Congress
were going to be playing such a damaging role
in the national discussion and within the
House of Representatives.
I certainly knew they were wacky.
I certainly knew they were radical.
I certainly knew they were ignorant, but I
didn't expect that they would become this
weaponized so quickly.
And today we're going to talk a little bit
about radical Congresswoman Marjorie Taylor
Greene.
Now, Marjorie Taylor Green, we spoke about
last week as a reminder, Marjorie Taylor Greene,
a Republican, is a new Kuhnen conspiracy theorist
and she believes that the Kuhnen stuff is
worth listening to.
She has previously said Muslims don't belong
in government and swearing on the Koran is
not allowed.
She has made claims about 9/11 that are certainly
a very, very far from what we know to be the
facts, which we'll talk about a little bit
later.
She has talked about the possibility of staged
elements of the Parkland's Sandy Hook and
Las Vegas shootings and also harassed David
Hogge, one of the students who was a student
at Marjory Stoneham High School, St. Stoneman
Stoneham.
I always forget Stoneman in Parkland, Florida,
and she has also previously posted on her
Facebook pages that Democratic officials should
be executed.
Well, there has now been a Facebook post from
two years ago uncovered whether where Marjorie
Taylor Green appears to be talking about some
kind of secret Jewish controlled space laser
that may be responsible for wildfires.
Let's take a look at it.
This is from November of twenty eighteen where
Green said, I'm posting this in speculation
because there are too many coincidences to
ignore.
And just putting it out there from some research
I've done, by the way, what these people define
as research is often funny from my curiosity
over PG&E stocks, which tanked all week, then
rallied Thursday night after California official
announced they would not let PG&E fail.
I find it very interesting that Roger Kimmell
on the board of directors of PG&E is also
vice chairman of Rothschild Inc, International
Investment Banking Firm.
Oh, I also find it interesting the long history
of financial contributions that PG&E has made
to Jerry Brown over the years, millions spent
in lobbying.
What a coincidence.
It must be that Governor Brown signed a bill
in September of twenty eighteen protecting
PG&E and allowing PG&E to pass office most
of fire responsibility to its customers and
rate hikes and through bonds.
It also must be just a coincidence that the
fires are burning in the same projected areas
that the 77 billion dollar high speed rail
project is being built is to be built, which
also happens to be Governor Brown's pet project.
And what are the odds that Feinstein's husband,
another another Jewish person, Richard Bloom,
another Jewish person, is the contractor on
the rail project?
Just with that much money, we could build
three southern border walls.
Then oddly, there are all these people who
have said they saw what looked like lasers
or blew by beams of light, causing the fires
and pictures and videos.
I don't know anything about that, but I find
it really curious.
Pogany's partnership with Celeron on
space
solar generators.